hello everyone and welcome to not one
but two really nice games from the
Chester B Masters finals it is Magnus
Carlson versus Dennis lazovic and well
well Dennis might not be you know among
the the elite In classical chess I
believe he's 2563 in classical chess uh
when it comes to speed chess rapid Blitz
bullet he uh can definitely play with
the best of them last year he defeated
Sam savian and he won the division two
of the uh of the Champions Chester and
now he qualified for division one where
he faces the the elite players and uh
yeah you'll you'll see how how strong he
is as um he lost game one to Magnus then
game two ended in a draw uh this is game
three and we are also going to check out
game four now sometimes I don't like
showing more than one game in one video
sometimes if it's a shorter game or a
shorter time form it then I will do it
here I decided to do so but you know you
can also just check out one of them you
don't have to watch both of them uh but
I suggest you do as usual so let's check
it out Magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to C4 so Dennis he is
down a point uh and he would very much
like to bounce back in the match uh but
you know it's going to be hard with the
black pieces against Magnus so Knight to
F6 Knight to C3 E5 we have Knight to F3
and as usual the Four Knights of the
English uh Knight to C6 G3 we have Pawn
to D5 striking in the center captures
captures uh and the bishop to G2 fining
the light sare Bishop Bishop to C5 and
both players Castle so castles castles
D3 uh and pawn to H6 we have Knight
captures on D5 Queen captures and now
Bishop to D2 uh preparing to maybe shift
the bishop over to C3 and put more
pressure on that E5 Pawn so Rook to d8
uh and queen to C2 we have Queen back to
D6 now you don't want your queen uh well
in front of that Bishop for for the
entire game A3 preparing PA to B4 and of
course A5 stopping that we have Rook a
to C1 putting pressure on the bishop and
then his goes back Bishop to B6 and now
also the Knight will be able to move as
the C7 Pawn is nicely defended so Bishop
to E3 uh and Bishop to E6 and
interestingly there is a game that
reached this exact same position and
believe it or not Dennis lazic had it
with the black pieces against param
makulu in the world Blitz championship
of 2023 now it's hard to say if Magnus
actually knew this or you know of course
he did prepare to uh to play against
Dennis before the game but you know uh
remembering a Blitz game from from 3
years ago uh I I know Magnus knows a lot
but it would be it would be weird to
think that um you know he actually knew
that this game was played but in that
game maulu continued with Queen to A4
and queen to A4 is one of the top engine
moves the other top engine moves are
Bishop captur on B6 and also Knight to
D2 and Magnus goes for Bishop captur on
B6 the other top engine move and it is
now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game so ended that one
against param makulu ended in the draw
if you guys are interested so uh here C
captures on B6 and now Queen to A4 and
Bishop to D5 so they uh ret transpose
into the game uh La played against
Parham and in that game Rook F to D1 was
played but now we have Pawn to E3 by
Magnus and it is not as of move 17 that
we really have a completely new game so
this time for real and interesting in
the the game uh against param param left
his Pawn on E2 for the rest of the game
he never he never Advanced at the E3 or
to E4 H but okay Rook eight to C8 and
now Rook to C3 Magnus wants to double up
on the C file param also uh went for
this idea Knights to E7 and now Rook F
to C1 H we have a trade on C3 Rook
captures Rook captures and Bishop to C6
so okay Dennis has the doubl pawns on
the B file but he wants to kick away
magnus's Queen Queen and then play B5
and B4 so Queen back to D1 and now Pawn
to B5 uh we have Queen to E1 uh and now
Pawn to B4 a captures and now not a
captures and B4 but Knight to D5
attacking the rook and the pawn so the
idea is when Magnus moves The Rook he
will recapture on B4 with the Knight but
Magnus says Nope I already grabbed one
Pawn I will take another and he plays
Rook captures on C6 here Magnus
sacrifices the pawn uh sorry the
exchange B captures and now UND doubles
his pawns while enjoying his two extra
pawns now and he does have the past a
pawn so he can put a queen behind the
pawn he already has a bishop on this
diagonal guarding the queening square
could be could be very nice but Dennis
replies with the strongest move C5 uh
this prevents Magnus from advancing the
pawn to D4 which sort of cements the
weakness on D3 and he will now go after
it with Knight to B4 and there there's
really no good way for Magnus to defend
it or rather there is uh but you have to
play A6 and give up the A6 Pawn the idea
is that after A6 Queen captures you will
capture the Knight on the pawn on E5 and
after Knight B before going after the
pawn bishop to F1 nicely
holds uh so that's the idea but after C5
Knight to D2 was played by Magnus he
wants to go after the pawn this way but
now it's a little bit different Knight
to B4 Knight to C4 and now Queen
captures on D3 this is a uh this is a
spectacular move by Dennis as Knight
captures on E5 would be punished
severely if if Magnus went for Knight
captures on E5 uh do you see what the
punishment was uh even feel free to
pause the video and try to spot this
idea even though it wasn't played in the
game it's really really nice so wh while
I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do this congratulations on being
a great Punisher of bad moves and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to see to the threat
being Rook to D1 to win the White Queen
and once you prevent that with Bishop to
F3 now comes F6 and where can the Knight
go does doesn't matter also the queen
covers G6 so you can't go there but if
you go Knight to G4 then look at this
Knight to D3 attacks the queen also puts
pressure on the F2 Pawn the only way to
defend is Queen to F1 uh and now just uh
F5 and uh the Knight is lost there is no
squares um left for this Knight and you
just win a piece so that's why after
this queen captures on D3 move Knight
captures on E5 is impossible Magnus
figures this out plays Queen Bishop to
F1 and uh he didn't take a lot he spent
some 30 seconds but he decided okay that
we cannot play that Queen back to D5 and
now Queen to A1 so okay he gave up a
pawn but the Knight is defended the
queen is ready to escort the pawn up the
board uh Dennis plays Knight to D3 and
now the bishop no longer defends the
Knight and he just wants to win a piece
here so Magnus has to defend Pawn to B3
and now Queen to F3 going after the F2
Pawn Magnus defends Queen to A2 and now
look at this Knight to C1 beautiful move
by Dennis now attacking the queen and uh
where do you where do you move the Queen
the problem is let's say you play Queen
to C2 uh all of a sudden Rook to D1
comes and you resign there's no way to
defend this because what do you play you
play A6 uh Rook captures on F1 is the
idea and after King captures Queen to H1
will be Checkmate as the Knight covers
the E2 Square so Magnus of course
figures this out he plays Knight
captures on E5 attacks Dennis's Queen on
F3 and now Queen to E4 of course he
doesn't have to trade Queens he will
just attack the Knight while the queen
is hanging and now there's no good way
for Magnus to save his Knight if he
tries something like uh well what can he
try Queen to B2 to defend the Knight
again Rook D1 with the exact same idea
of just sacrificing the rook and then
Queen H1 Checkmate you can play some F3
but then Queen captures an E3 with check
and you you just fall up part so instead
after Queen E4 Queen to A4 Magnus now
has to part with his Knight and queen
captures an E5 Pawn to A6 but okay
Magnus still has the past a pawn uh
Queen to D5 and now Pawn to A7 so
basically Magnus is not down down a
knight he's down a full Rook as uh there
was an exchange sacrifice before Magnus
now sort of uh had to give back the
piece and now Rook to A8 uh St stopping
the advancement of the pass pawn and
okay for the moment as long as Magnus
has the past Pawn on A7 Dennis's Rook is
out of the game but if Dennis is able to
somehow move the queen take the Rook
take the pawn uh he will just be up a
full Rook so okay we have Queen to B5
now preparing Queen to B8 uh Queen to d8
stopping that we have Queen to
B7 uh now putting pressure on on D F7
pawn bishop to C4 is coming uh Knight
captures on B3 with have Bishop to C4
and now Knight to D2 attacking the
bishop and inviting Bishop captures on
F7 and here best would be to play Bishop
to D5 but um it's already it's already
very hard to play Magnus has some 30
seconds on the clock Dennis has 12
seconds on the clock and finding a move
like Bishop to D5 uh is you know asking
a bit much the the point is that after
Bishop to D5 Rook captures on A7 uh you
you don't capture and then Queen
captures on D5 now you play Bishop
captures on F7 check and you take the
Rook while Defending Your Bishop H but
after the immediate Bishop captures an
F7 then it's just moved the king and now
you can't really do all that much
um uh there's no uh there there's no
such such trickery left and you don't
really have a move if Bishop to D5 now
now Rook captures on A7 is a move you
capture it and then Queen captures
bishop and you're just down a down a
full Knight so instead after King to h8
King to G2 was played sort of trying to
improve the position a little bit but
now Pawn to C4 the pawn marches forward
uh we have Bishop to G6 uh trying to
create some sort of a mating net maybe
you move the bishop maybe you get the
queen into the game somehow uh but yeah
if not that means Dennis will just pick
up the pawn and will just be up in
material but also the pass Pawn is
marching forward C3 uh Bishop to C2 and
now Queen to C8 forcing magnus's Queen
to move back Queen to F7 and now Queen
to C6 with check we have Pawn to E4 and
now Queen to B6 you could also uh
capture on e4 I mean for example Queen
captures and then Knight captures and
then Queen to F3 but uh it's maybe
giving up a little bit too much but
still after Rook captures on A7 you will
be able to capture on e4 but then Rook
to F7 and again black is winning but
both of them are constantly below the
the the 10sec mark and uh uh well you
you just can't afford to calculate this
much so Queen to B6 was played Now Pawn
to E5 Magnus starts advancing his pass
Pawn uh and queen captures on A7 it
would be it would be a great mistake to
play Rook captures on A7 because by
playing E5 magnets also opened up this
diagonal so I hope none of you forgot
about our good friend the bishop on C2
so instead after E5 just Queen captures
on A7 Dennis eliminates the pawn and now
Queen to F5 Magnus threatens Checkmate
and Dennis plays King to G8 so all of a
sudden Magnus starts a king hunt Queen
to H7 with check King to F7 Queen to G6
with check King to f8 and now Pawn to E6
now you have to guard df7 square at all
times otherwise you're getting
checkmated Queen to B7 check King to H3
and now Queen to E7 we have Queen to F5
with check and queen to F6 Queen to D5
going after the rook and now Rook to E8
so defending everything and getting
ready to uh claim the D6 pawn and once
that is claimed then Magnus will just be
down a full Rook so Bishop to F5
stopping the capture of the pawn Pawn uh
King to G8 he does now escape with the
King and there's no more uh tricks that
Magnus can use to even prolong the game
he does go for E7 with check but now
King to h8 Queen to D7 going after the
rook and just Queen captures an E7 H
this was one last trick if Rook captures
on E7 then okay Queen to C8 and you will
Checkmate the black king but of course
Denis will not fall for that he played
Queen cap on E7 and he was in this
position un move 55 that Magnus Carlson
resigned the game uh as there is nothing
more uh to be done here so Dennis
equalized the match and now there is one
more game to be played and Dennis has
the white pieces so it's a good uh you
know maybe psychological Edge you just
defeated Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces and now you have uh the the white
pieces in the final game uh so of course
uh he will do his best to win this and I
will show you this one as well because
it's a very very tricky game so let's uh
shift the the colors now Dennis with the
wi pieces opens with Pawn to D4 we have
Pawn to D5 by Magnus C4 C6 and Knight to
F3 we have Knight to F6 E3 and Bishop to
G4 uh the the col system uh we have H3
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Pawn to E6 so uh we usually say that in
these Queen Pawn openings uh Black's
light Square Bishop is the most
problematic piece to develop so Magnus
just gives it up and says I no longer
have a problem piece I put my Pawns in
light squares I have a bishop to you
know just go uh in between those uh
pawns and light squares and I will have
have a very nice game so okay Knight to
C3 we have Knight B to D7 Bishop to D3
and Bishop to B4 all been play before
nothing new here gold players castle and
now Rook to D1 we have Rook to E8 uh and
queen back to E2 we have Queen to E7
both players um developing the queen
Magnus also nicely connects his Rooks uh
Bishop to D2 and now D captures on C4 we
have Bishop captures and now uh there is
a game where Knight to B6 was played but
here we have Bishop back to D6 and it is
now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game and both of them
equal time uh 9 Minutes both um so they
just you know blitzed this out without
any issues and we have Pawn to E4 by
Dennis he wants to win a piece with Pawn
to E5 so Magnus plays Pawn to E5 himself
and now Pawn to D5 now the uh you you
did grab more space but you weaken the
C5 Square so Magnus puts the bishop on
C5 and puts pressure on this diagonal
now well you could play something like
Rook eight to C1 and it would make sense
you develop a piece you're you know
x-raying that Bishop uh Bishop to E3
first so okay Magnus trades Bishop
captures Queen captures and he
immediately offers a queen trade uh but
while you could capture this then it
goes back Queen to E2 it's not uncommon
for for players to just trust Magnus
when he offers a queen trade uh Knight
to B6 we have Bishop to B3 and now C
captures on D5 Knight captures on D5 we
have Knight Capt sorry Knight B captures
on D5 Bishop captures on D5 and queen to
E7 uh you you have to guard the pawn
somehow and you also know Rook 8 to C1
is coming so it makes sense to move the
queen queen E7 Rook 8 to C1 and now Rook
8 to C8 we have Bishop back to B3 and
just Rook e to d8 and if you look at
this position now it's pretty
symmetrical pretty equal uh Dennis does
have a bishop against the Knight okay
it's play on both sides of the board so
maybe you will have some sort of an edge
if you uh trade both r and the queen but
objectively it should be should be very
equal Rook captures and C8 was played
Rook captures G3 and G6 we have Pawn to
A3 and King to G7 uh King to G2 Now Pawn
to B6 both players improving their
position as much as possible and queen
to F3 now maybe if everything moves then
you will have some pressure against that
F7 Pawn but Rook to d8 and now Rook to
D3 Magnus does trade Rook captures Queen
captures and now just Queen to to C5 uh
asking uh what do you do here I'm
putting some pressure on your king side
I'm also maybe preparing Queen to C1 uh
so what do you play here well uh Bishop
to C4 Dennis cannot offer a queen trade
as the queen is for the moment stuck
guarding D4 Pawn so he plays Bishop to
C4 he stops Magnus infiltrating with his
Queen and now Magnus grabs more space
Pawn to A5 stopping Pawn to B4 uh King
to F3 bringing the king closer to the
action also defending the E4 pawn and
now the White Queen can move so Queen
back to C8 going after the H3 pawn and
thennis goes back King to G2 we have
Queen to C6 and Dennis repeats King to
F3 but now Magnus does not repeat he
wants to continue the game Pawn to H5
okay we have Bishop to B3 uh and now uh
how do you how do you continue this well
you could play something like Pawn to H4
maybe try to weaken the king side but
Magnus goes Pawn to B5 we have Bishop
back to D5 and now Queen to D7 uh taking
the the bishop does doesn't really do
all that much plus you give Dennis a
pass Pawn so maybe you know if you don't
have to do this maybe try something else
Magnus repeats once Queen to D7 goes
after the H3 pawn and King back to G2
and now King to f8 Magnus starts
bringing the king into the game we have
Pawn to B4 and pawn to A4 and now if you
look at the queen side uh Dennis does
not have does have a light Square bishop
and Magnus put uh both of his pawns on
light Square so maybe somehow if you're
able to move the queen let's say get the
bishop let's say to E2 to put pressure
on the B5 pawn and maybe also join in
with the queen maybe it could be a
weakness but the problem is as soon as
Dennis starts planning something like
this Magnus will say okay we're just not
going to allow that we'll just play
Knight captur on D5 so while it is uh
could be dangerous uh you know
realistically there's very little chance
that it will happen uh so the question
is whether Dennis is ready to call it a
day or does he want to play for more if
you want to call it a day you play H4
and then it's basically up to Magnus
whether he will capture on D5 or not but
without capturing on D5 there's very
little you can do to actually you know
prolong the game uh but after A4 Dennis
played Pawn to F4 he wants the he he
wants to play this for a win and he
wants to complicate matters and okay e
captures G captures and now Queen to C7
now the situation on the clock is also
very relevant here Magnus has 4 minutes
and then it's 2 minutes and 20 seconds
and he has the this de side whether he
wants to defend the pawn whether he
wants to stop Queen to C1 uh what does
he want to do here H now if you the idea
let's say if you play King to F3 is that
Queen to C1 is just really annoying and
it's really really hard to play this
like you play E5 Queen to H1 check and
already you blunder a piece and uh after
Queen to C7 you you could play E5 right
away uh which is definitely the way to
go let's say you trade everything
captures captures now you allow the
black queen down the board and now you
cannot play G3 because just uh Queen to
B3 uh gives a check and also connects
with the the the White Queen and if you
trade then this Pawn becomes a pass pawn
and it easily promotes so you will have
to play King to F3 and now after this
check you will have to defend your queen
with the King and now you allow Queen
captures on H3 but then Queen captures
on B5 and okay the game continues but uh
again with perfect play should be a draw
so after Queen to C7 uh Queen to D2 was
played again Dennis uh sort of trusts
Magnus he he he defends the F4 pawn and
stops the infiltration with the queen
and now we have King to E7 here Queen to
D6 was very strong but to to a little
time on the clock to figure figure out
why and also to maybe allow pwn to E5 uh
but it was a very strong point is that
after you do this let's say King F3 now
you play Queen to D7 and you're either
winning this Pawn or if the king defends
then you will capture on e4 and win this
Pawn as well the bishop is pinned so
that's the idea but after Queen Queen D2
Magnus started bringing his King into
the game King E7 and now Pawn to E5
definitely the best move Knight captures
Queen captures and queen to D7 again
offering a queen trade and while it is
best to accept this Dennis uh again
trusts Magnus Queen to C5 with check or
maybe he doesn't trust him maybe he just
figures that this is more tricky and he
will also try to to beat Magnus the
problem is he's down to 20 seconds on
the clock and Magnus has 2 and A2
minutes so King to E6 we have King to G3
three now Queen to D3 uh with check uh
and here we have King to H4 and the
position is now completely winning for
Magnus but uh this move is extremely
hard to find I will even ask you to
pause the video here and try to spot
this winning idea for Magnus while I
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is paon to G five with check that's the
key and the reason is that if you
capture with the pawn you allow this
check and you cannot allow a queen trade
uh because your pawns will just be
unstoppable to give you an example even
King captures on H5 you just trade
queens and now you have to eliminate the
E5 Pawn first if you if you just start
pushing then having three pawns that
white can push will be a problem for
black but if you capture one Pawn then
it's not a problem for example captures
captures and now B4 will be winning
captures a three and your Pawn is just
becoming a queen much much sooner than
uh White's pawns and another thing after
this uh well after King H4 if you play
Pawn to G5 check is that if you capture
with the King doesn't matter if you
capture the G Pawn or the H Pawn uh your
queen to G3 check or queen captures on
H3 if you capture the the other opponent
and after King captures you will capture
here and after King G5 Queen F5 check
and after King to H4 or you go up the
board and then you just get checkmated
uh then you collect the F4 Pawn PA with
check and after King H3 Queen F3 check
and after King the H4 Queen E4 check and
you will either force a queen trade or
you will win the E5 Pawn for example
King H3 Queen to D3 check King to H2 and
now Queen to D5 either forces a queen
trade or you will you know just give a
check give up the pawn now black is up a
pawn and of course everyone knows that
in a queen and pawn end game up a pawn
means a winning end game so that's the
idea behind um uh Pawn to G5 but Magnus
missed it he played King King to F5 and
now he allows a draw Pawn to E6 with
check King captures on E6 and queen to
E5 with check we have King to D7 uh King
to G5 we have Queen captures on H3 and
now Queen captures on B5 with check King
E7 Queen to C5 with check King to E8 and
queen to E5 with check we have Queen
back to E6 Magnus is up a pawn so of
course he wants to trade Queens but just
Queen to B8 with check King D7 Queen to
C7 with check and and now King to f8 and
here again a problematic position
because there is only one move that
doesn't lose for Dennis uh and Dennis
doesn't find it and I mean you you can't
uh really be you know uh confused by
that uh he he did play most of his last
like 20 moves with 5 Seconds on the
clock uh here King H6 is the only move
that allows you to draw point is that
after King H6 doesn't really M doesn't
matter what you play if you play Pawn to
G5 check uh then you can just capture on
H5 and after let's say queen to G6 check
you will move the king king to G4 and
now if captures captures this is enough
for a draw and if um you just prepare
with Queen to F6 now K G5 will be
preparation for checkmate uh now you
just start checking the black king queen
to C8 check King to E7 Queen to C7 with
check King to f8 Queen to C8 with check
and so on and so on will be a draw by uh
three-fold repetition but in the game
Queen to E5 was played and now the
position is just winning for Magnus
Queen captures on E5 but Magnus doesn't
find it the winning idea here F6 check
is actually winning for Magnus uh but
Magnus also down to 10 seconds doesn't
find it point is that after Queen
captures you trade Queens you play H4
the pawn is just Unstoppable there's no
way to catch to catch the pawn uh but
after king queen to E5 Queen captures on
E5 was played Magnus goes for a queen
trade King to E7 and now uh you have to
play Pawn to B5 this is the way to
continue the Game Force the black king
to move and then infiltrate with King to
F6 but then it's played King to F4 uh
and this just gives Magnus the E6 square
and now it's just not the same King to
E6 and now King to E4 and the problem is
B5 doesn't really do anything as you
have Pawn to H4 and then if you advance
at King to D7 you will be able to stop
both of the pawns and uh yeah just
doesn't doesn't work we have King to E4
Pawn to G5 Now by Magnus and now the two
connected pass pawns are just too strong
to uh to face King to D4 we have Pawn to
H4 King to E4 Now Pawn to H3 King to F3
and here King captures on E5 and he was
in this position and move 61 that Dennis
lazovic resigned the game and with it
the the the match so Magnus Carlson wins
the finals of the chville Masters 2024
but it doesn't matter as we still have
the you know finals of the losers
bracket and then they go into the Grand
Final and then Magnus will face someone
who will face Dennis lavic in the Grand
Final uh here I can even show it to you
uh there we have it this is the official
one so Magnus defeated lazovic is's in
the Grand Final and lazovic is in the
losers final now waiting for the winner
of the semi-final match between uh Yan
pishi and ala fua so Dennis will face
one of them and then whoever wins will
face Magnus in the Grand Final so we
might see Magnus versus lzic Magnus
versus ala fua or Magnus versus Yani
pishi whoever emerges Victorious and for
those of you who are maybe new to to
chess I can also show you why this is
winning as well once you attack the pawn
uh just G4 you cannot capture on G4
because then the H Pawn cannot be
stopped and uh if B5 you just play Pawn
to F5 now there's no move white can make
for example you play B6 King to D6 you
go after the Pawn King H2 you just March
the pawns forward King to G1 G3 doesn't
really matter B7 you will stop the pawn
and after King to H1 just F3 for example
King G1 H2 check King F1 and H to
bringing a queen or even you know if you
want to be awesome you can bring a rook
into the game and it will also be
Checkmate uh so yeah very nicely done by
by Dennis and you can see how a lot of
these young players still don't have
their classical rating to 26 2650 2700
but in Rapid and Blitz chess they can
they can definitely fight the the
strongest chess players as you can see
even Dennis here is almost 2800 in in
online rapid uh so you never know how
how strong these young players are he's
only 17 years old and I mean he took
down Magnus with the black pieces that's
absolutely amazing uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by both of them but mag Magnus
takes the win in in the match I would
like to thank Gard tlan Jeremy antios
Carl Weinberg rajashri churi and David
gasparian for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day